I was waiting for this fashion moment
you look gorgeous good to see you really
look breathtaking and I know I'm not
supposed to start with that but you
can't walk up here looking like this not
having me say anything thank you okay so
first things first we talked about it a
little bit but the more I thought about
this movie the more I thought why are
Bri and Sam so odd but just so perfect
to get me seriously yeah I don't know
it's weird to us too but now we just
roll with it it's just like we're the
comedic duo you didn't know you needed
I'm so glad that I got it now definitely
me too I feel so lucky that I found at
this stage in my life like my person so
now we just you know we're just trying
to figure out what our next three movies
will be come on you can write it you can
direct it you can do whatever you want
he's in now from what I understand
Marvel knew years before this that they
were gonna open this movie on
International Women's Day it was always
in their plan that is brilliant that's
special just shows like that they're
being pointed as well as to like what
this movie means or what it can mean I
should say I was listening to Tina Brown
interview today and she was talking
about her women of the world conference
and she said guess who we had brie
Larson Captain Marvel and Oprah Oprah
in that tribe of women to really speak
to what we can do to improve the space
that were in now and what capably oh
there's I mean of course it's always
gonna be room to improve but those are
all women that I like look to and listen
to when I'm feeling like lost so to be
included with them is kind of surreal to
be honest how about tonight you're
shutting down Hollywood Boulevard I know
I don't know if I'm ever gonna make
sense to me
[Music]